SHELBY: Willie!
Hey!
What's going on?
STEVE ROREX: Hey, man.
DAN FEARS: What are you doing?
I was trying to catch
a fish, but my rod broke.
What y'all up to, huh?
Shelby had been downriver
for a couple of years now.
We heard he's back.
It's really exciting
for us, 'cause
we're in such desperate need
of some good wood right now.
We heard you been downriver
We've been looking for you.
SHELBY: Shut up, [inaudible]!
We're from Southern Wood.
We got a shop down the
road, not too far from here.
You got any logs?
SHELBY: Yeah, I got a few, man.
I got some right there.
I got two.
Yeah, we-- we need
a few more than that.
DAN FEARS: Big.
We've got a huge oar we've
been trying to get field--
SHELBY: [blows nose]
STEVE ROREX: And
we've been going
through several
different log guys,
and nobody can do
what we need to do.
Well, how much is it?
STEVE ROREX: We, uh, we
need to get at least 10,000
board feet of sinker cypress.
Is that something
you think you can do?
[laughs]
DAN FEARS: We got--
Well, how much
money y'all got down?
You can put any
money down on it?
Well, we'd give
you a big deposit.
Well, let me have it.
Well, we need to
see some logs first.
How soon do you need it?
How soon can you get it?
Well, hell, I
ain't psychic yet.
Now as soon as I
get it, I get it.
DAN FEARS: All right, man.
I mean, I'll get it as
fast as I can get it, man.
I mean--
- We in a tight rush, you know.
We got to get this
thing processed.
[bleep] right, man.
Ho, we needing it bad.
What's your name again?
- Steve.
SHELBY: [bleep] Oh, man.
That sounds good, man.
STEVE ROREX: Good.
DAN FEARS: Pretty exciting.
One big-ass damn order, man.
What the [bleep] I
got myself into now?
Here we go, Junior!
NARRATOR: So today,
he's thinking big.
I've got a pretty
good idea where I might
find a bunch of good logs.
NARRATOR: Heading
to a bend downriver,
hunting for a log
raft rumored to have
sunk over 100 years ago.
- Right there.
Dead ahead.
What is that?
Oh, that's cable
from the big log.
That's the raft!
Ah-ho, there he is.
It was there.
DONNA: Is that a
piece of the raft?
SHELBY: That's the raft.
My boy.
NARRATOR: Now there's an old
saying, where there's smoke,
there's fire.
And right about now--
SHELBY: So damn
close I can feel it.
NARRATOR: --Shelby's
getting hot.
I think I might have found
some damn sunken treasure.
Come on, Junior!
DONNA: That must be
a log right there.
Yeah.
See it bubbling?
There it is!
Ha, ha, ha!
Got that done.
Boy, it's a good one, Papaw!
That's a good
one, right there.
Yee-haw!
We on top of it now, Junior!
It's only one log, but
it's a damn good start.
Let's see the rest
of that raft, Papaw.
Oh, here we go!
Dig it downwards, baby!
Oh!
Plenty more where that came.
DONNA: Woo, it's raining logs!
Woo!
Ah ho, we got 'em,
getting them now.
DONNA: This a gold
mine right here, man.
I knew this damn raft
was down here, man.
There's a whole
bunch of them here.
Get it go gone now, Junior, with
all the damn logs we got now.
How'd you like that, Papaw!
Oh, my gosh.
NARRATOR: After two
years on the sidelines,
Shelby came back with empty
pockets and a determination
to fill them.
And using every trick he
knows, the swamp man's
hustling his way right
back onto the gravy train.
My mama didn't raise no
fool, and my daddy didn't
raise no idiot, so here we go.
NARRATOR: But Shelby ain't
just helping himself.
STEVE ROREX: Shelby!
What y'all doing?
You been working on our order?
Yeah.
I been getting here's some
logs right here I got for it.
Look at them big ones.
DAN FEARS: That's nice.
NARRATOR: Thanks to the swamp
man, the boys at Southern Wood
could be on to the big time.
These logs are
looking great so far.
Primo logs, great logs.
I just want to make sure
you're good with this,
and you got everything.
SHELBY: Damn right.
I got it, man.
This is just hopefully
the first of many.
You know, if everything is this
good or better moving forward--
We're going to be in
a, we'll be sitting high.
--Shelby's going to hit
one out the park for us.
Yeah.
SHELBY: Thank y'all, Steve, Dan.
See y'all.
Ho, here we go, and oh my
god, we gonna be good now.